petit à petit ces images deviennent de
plus en plus familière pour nous les
français
cet été notre mois de juillet était
rythmée par la pluie et les orages et la
grisaille mais alors pourquoi connais
ton ce temps et surtout à quoi vont
ressembler nos prochains étés on tente
d'y voir plus clair dans facture
[Musique]
d'abord l'été 2021 est il vraiment aussi
moche on le dit quand on regarde les
moyennes de températures on est pile
dans les normales de saison surprise
avec 20,7 degrés de moyenne à l'échelle
nationale ces températures correspondent
à ce que l'on a connu entre 1980 et 2010
c'est au niveau des précipitations que
ça coince avec un surplus de pluie de
43% c'est le septième mois de juillet le
plus arrosé depuis 1959 on a retrouvé un
été particulièrement arrosés alors que
ces six derniers étés ont été
remarquablement chaud et sec sur la
france sur la période mi juin à mi
juillet des records absolus depuis il
n'avait jamais autant plu en france
entre le 15 juin et le 15 juillet
pourtant lorsque l'on regarde à
l'échelle européenne ce mois de juillet
était le plus chaud jamais enregistré
posant de violents incendies ans est-ce
en italie
ou en turquie
si l'on n'a pas connu cette vague de
chaleur c'est à cause de cette goutte
froide venus de l'atlantique est venu se
positionner juste sur l'ouest de
l'europe dont la france une goutte
froide c'est une masse d'air venues du
nord elle circule en général tout autour
de la terre bloqués au sud par un
courant d'air qu'on appelle le jet
stream seulement ce courant d'air n'est
pas linéaire et a tendance à aussi y est
ce qui permet aux dépressions de
s'échapper et de descendre ce phénomène
n'est pas rare du tout mais en général
on le connaît surtout au printemps et
c'est lui qui est à l'origine du mauvais
temps se traduit par les averses de
grêle de grésil de neige fondue au
printemps et ça se traduit tout
simplement par les giboulées le principe
des giboulées de mars c'est lié à ces
gouttes froides cet été cette masse
d'air qui a longtemps stationné est à
l'origine de fortes inondations qu'ont
connue l'allemagne et la belgique au
mois de juillet
[Musique]
et
ce problème dès 6 heures
mais ces gouttes froides sont elles dues
au changement climatique
l'affluence sur le jet ski mais pas
complètement clair mais les structures
de gouttes froide où les structures de 2
mais andres ne sont pas on observait
d'aucune modification qui a été attribué
au chant
pourtant on observe tout de même des
changements dans ces dépressions la
douche froide elle même n'est pas une
fréquente mais le contenu
de vapeur d'eau et la température
se sont plus chaudes d'une manière
générale 40 dans ce tour le même type de
phénomène alors à quoi vont ressembler
nos prochains était sous l'influencé du
changement climatique sur d'épée de
damoclès c'est à dire qu'ils étaient
risque de poser problème il est possible
qu'à cause des gouttes froides mais
aussi des orages classique on est des
événements de plus en plus violents
l'europe sera soumise à une plus grande
fréquence depuis extrême et le plus
grande intensité aussi de ses plus
extrême des céans données sur et même si
le temps est au beau fixe cela peut
aussi poser problème à cause de
l'augmentation des températures soit
alors on se retrouvera dans dix excès de
chaleur et de canicule rien de
réjouissant donc pour nos prochains étés
le giec ayant estimé le réchauffement de
la planète d'un véhicule 5 degrés pour
2030 lors de sa précédente estimation ce
réchauffement était prévu pour 2040
[Musique]